the that is the best talking I've ever
seen and he didn't have to do it he just
called up his guy hey yeah just announce
usk when do you want fight him uh what
are we in uh do it in December I'm a
little worried if I'm fan I'm like oh
man that's he really thinks me that easy
huh yeah yeah yeah they do they're not
taking it serious at all he's using you
as basically live sparring before he
fights usk that's how much respect he
has on the other side of that Ivon
Francis all right okay this is good he's
not taking this serious and when you hit
as hard as Francis does I don't care who
you are there's no man walking this
planet who can take a flush right or
left hook from Francis and ganu and wake
up it's not going to happen he has that
freaking African nuke in the back of his
pocket Tyson has to just maybe glance at
the clock in one millisecond and that
that right hand comes through left hand
comes through and this thing's over it's
the biggest upset in Combat Sports
history